Krylov 양자 대각화, 줄여서 KQD는 행렬 고유값
문제를 Krylov 방법에 따라 양자 컴퓨터에서 준비된 부분 공간으로 투영해서 푸는 방법이에요. 이건
고전 선형대수에서 나온 강력한 접근법이에요. 이 영상에서는 Krylov 방법이 어디에 유용한지,
그리고 양자 컴퓨터에서 언제 어떻게 구현하는지 살펴볼 거예요.
그러면 Krylov 방법이 뭘까요? 과학이나 비즈니스 문제와 관련된 n행 n열짜리 행렬 H가 있다고 해봐요.
우리는 가장 낮은 고유값 e0와 그에 대응하는 고유벡터 사이즈0에 관심이 있어요. 초기
벡터 v를 정의해봐요. 이건 h의 구조에서 착안하거나 완전히 무작위로 선택할 수 있어요. 차수 r의 Krylov 부분 공간,
즉 k r은 이 초기 벡터에 h를 작용시켜서
r minus 1번 반복하고, 각 h 작용의 결과를 기저 벡터 집합에 추가해서 만들어요.
즉, kr은 벡터 v로 생성되는 공간이에요.
hv, h 제곱, 이런 식으로 계속돼요. 이 벡터들은 일반적으로 직교하지 않아요.
고전적으로는 Graham-Schmidt 절차와 매우 유사한 직교화 과정을 수행하는 경우가 많아요. 초기
벡터 V를 정규화해서 그 결과를 V0이라고 불러요. 그 다음 벡터 HV의 경우, V0 위로의
투영을 빼서 두 벡터를 직교하게 만들어요. 그런 다음 결과를 정규화해요. 이 과정을 계속해서,
H를 다시 작용시키고 결과를 이전에 추가된 모든 벡터에 직교하게 만들면서 R개를 쌓아가요.
R차원 Krylov 부분 공간을 생성하는 데 필요한 직교 정규화된 벡터들이죠.
이 부분 공간을 얻으면, 행렬을 거기에 투영하고 더 작은 투영 행렬을 대각화해요. 여러
세부 사항과 확장이 있지만, 이게 가장 간단한 수준의 Krylov 방법이에요.
어떻게 작동하는지 더 잘 이해하기 위해 간단한 예를 살펴봐요. H가 이 행렬이고 V가 이
벡터로 선택되면, 먼저 V를 정규화해요. Krylov 부분 공간에서 두 번째 벡터를 생성하려면, 초기 벡터에
H를 한 번 작용시키고 그 결과를 V0에 직교하게 만들어요.
간단한 대수 계산을 하면 V1이 이렇게 나와요.
이런 작은 행렬에는 유용하지 않고, 보통 Krylov 차원이 2에서 멈추지도 않아요. 하지만 만약
H를 새로운 Krylov 공간 K2로 투영하려면, 각 열이 Krylov 벡터인 행렬 V와
각 행이 Krylov 벡터인 켤레 전치 행렬을 사용해요. 그러면
이런 행렬을 얻게 돼요.
이 행렬은 기술적으로 원래 행렬보다 차원이 낮아요. 당연히 이 규모에서는 이런 축소가 유용하지 않아요.
이 방법은 수천 또는 수백만 행과 열을 가진 행렬을
소수로 줄이기 위한 거예요. 그러면 Krylov 방법이 왜 유용할까요? 이 간단한 처방,
즉 연산자 작용이 행렬 연산자의 가장 낮은 값 상태나 바닥 상태에 접근하는
가장 효율적인 방법인 경우가 많다는 게 밝혀졌어요. 좀 더 명확하게 해봐요. 전체 증명은 수반 텍스트에 맡길게요. 우리가
풀려는 문제는 벡터 x에 h가 작용하면 어떤 상수 곱하기 벡터 x가 되는 형태예요. 먼저
고유벡터 x0를 추측해봐요. 이건 단순히 근사해예요. 오차가 있는데 이를 e0라고 불러요. 이제 우리는
이 추측을 갱신하고 싶은데, 이를 x1이라고 부를게요. 이게 우리의 근사를 개선하길 기대해요. 이걸
원래의 x0에 아직 결정되지 않은 보정 p0를 더한 것으로 표현할 수 있어요.
이 과정을 더 많은 보정 벡터 pi를 추가하면서 반복적으로 계속할 수 있어요.
당연히 오차가 줄어들길 원하지만, 상태만 신경 쓰는 게 아니에요. 우리는 또한
그 상태에 h가 작용하는 것도 신경 써요. 그래서 실제로 최소화하려는 양은 이 오차의 h 노름,
즉 이 오차에 h가 작용한 것의 노름이에요.
이제 이게 p0를 포함하는 식임을 알 수 있고, p가 이 오차의 h 노름을
가장 효율적으로 최소화하는 선택이 무엇인지 물어볼 수 있어요. 어떤 공간에서 보정을 선택해야 할까요? 특정
조건, 예를 들어 h가 대칭이고 양의 정부호인 경우, kr 내에서 첫 번째 r개의 보정을 선택하는 것이
최적임이 밝혀져 있어요. 더 쉽게 말하면, 우리는 Hamiltonian을 투영할
좋은 부분 공간을 준비하는 방법이 필요해요. 그리고 많은 경우, Krylov 부분 공간이 초기 추측에 대한
가장 효율적인 보정들이 생성하는 공간이에요.
실제 증명은 이 영상에 수반된 텍스트를 참고해요.
지금까지 설명한 모든 것은 고전적으로도 할 수 있어요. 그렇다면 양자 컴퓨터는 언제 어떻게 사용할까요?
매우 큰 행렬의 경우, Krylov 방법은 긴 계산 시간과 많은 메모리를 필요로 할 수 있어요. V에
H를 행렬 연산하는 데 걸리는 시간은 최악의 경우 N 제곱에 비례해요.
그리고 이건 부분 공간에서 원하는 모든 벡터에 대해 수행돼요. 부분 공간 차원 R은 보통 N의
큰 비율이 아니고 종종 log N처럼 증가해요. 그래서 모든 벡터를 생성하는 건
N 제곱 log N 정도예요.
직교화 같은 다른 단계들도 있지만, 이게 기억해야 할 지배적인 스케일링이에요.
양자 컴퓨팅은 문제의 어떤 속성이 시간과 자원 스케일링을 결정하는지
바꿀 수 있어요. 전반적으로 행렬 크기 n에 의존하는 대신, 측정 횟수(shots)나
Hamiltonian을 구성하는 비가환 Pauli 항의 수 같은 것들이 보여요.
이게 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴봐요.
양자 상태를 시간 진화시키는 연산자가 iH를 h bar로 나눈 것의 지수 함수라는 걸 기억해요. 그리고
양자 컴퓨팅, 특히 표기법에서 h bar를 생략하는 게 매우 일반적이에요.
연산자의 지수 함수를 이해하고 실현하는 한 가지 방법은 Fourier
급수 전개를 보는 거예요. 이 연산이 초기 벡터 V에 작용하면 항들의 합이 나온다는 걸 알아두세요.
H의 거듭제곱이 초기 상태에 점점 더 많이 적용되면서요. 마치 시간 진화를 통해 Krylov 부분 공간을
만들 수 있을 것 같아요. 거의 맞아요. 주의할 점은
실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 시간 진화를 실현하는 방법이에요. Hamiltonian의 항들 중 많은 것들이 서로 교환하지 않아요.
그래서 e의 마이너스 i z 같은 단순한 지수 연산자들은 단순한
circuit에 대응하지만, 일반적인 Hamiltonian은 그렇지 않아요. 비가환 항들을 포함하기 때문에
숫자처럼 지수 함수를 단순한 것들의 곱으로 분해할 수가 없어요. 그래서
간단하지 않지만, 양자 컴퓨팅에서 잘 연구된 과정이에요. 양자 컴퓨터에서 시간 진화는
trotterization이라는 과정을 통해 수행하는데, 그 자체로도 풍부한 주제예요. 하지만 매우 높은 수준에서,
시간 진화를 작은 M개의 단계로 나눔으로써 항들의 비가환성 효과를 제한해요.
고전적인 맥락에서 H의 거듭제곱을 직접 사용해서 생성한 차수 r의 Krylov 부분 공간을
power Krylov 부분 공간 kpr이라고 부를게요.
이제 iht의 지수 함수로 주어지는 유니터리 시간 진화 연산자 u를 사용해서 유사한 공간을 생성해요.
이걸 unitary Krylov 공간 kur이라고 부를게요.
고전적으로 사용하는 power Krylov 부분 공간 kpr은 h가 유니터리 연산자가 아니기 때문에
양자 컴퓨터에서 직접 생성할 수 없어요. unitary Krylov 부분 공간을 사용하면
power Krylov 부분 공간과 유사한 수렴 보장을 줄 수 있다는 게 밝혀져 있어요.
구체적으로, 초기 상태 V가 진정한 바닥 상태와 지수적으로 소멸하지 않는 겹침을 가지고
있는 한, 그리고 고유 상태들 사이에 충분한 간격이 있는 한 바닥 상태 오차가 효율적으로 수렴해요.
여기서 u의 거듭제곱은 서로 다른 시간 단계가 돼요. u의 k번째 거듭제곱은
k * dt만큼 앞으로 나아가는 거예요.
총 시간 kdt만큼 시간 진화된 부분 공간의 원소를 s sub k로 표시할 수 있어요. Hamiltonian
H를 unitary Krylov 부분 공간 kur에 투영할 수 있어요. 다시 말해,
kur basis에서 h의 각 행렬 원소를 계산해요. 이
투영 행렬을 H tilde라고 부를게요. H tilde의 행렬 원소들은 양자 컴퓨터를 사용해서
추정할 수 있는 이러한 기댓값들로 주어져요.
H는 서로 다른 qubit들에 대한 Pauli 연산자들의 합으로 쓸 수 있고, 모든 Pauli 연산자를
동시에 측정할 수는 없다는 걸 기억해요. Pauli 항들을 교환하는 항들의 그룹으로 분류하고 한꺼번에 측정할 수 있어요.
하지만 모든 항을 다루려면 그런 그룹이 많이 필요할 수 있어요. 항들을 분류할 수 있는 교환 그룹의 수
ngcp가 중요해져요. 차원 r의 unitary Krylov 부분 공간을 사용하면
결과 행렬은 r * r 차원이 돼요. r이 n보다 훨씬 작으면
유용한 진전을 이룬 거고, 보통 r은 100보다 훨씬 작아서 고전 컴퓨터에서
쉽게 대각화할 수 있어요. 하지만 s n과 s m은 일반적으로 직교하지 않는다는 걸 기억해요.
비직교 basis에서 행렬을 대각화하는 것이 때로는 가능해요. 하지만 수치적, 물리적 이유로
먼저 직교 basis로 바꾸는 게 좋아요. 그래서 Gram 행렬 s를 사용해서 일반화된 고유값 문제를 풀어요.
Gram 행렬의 mn 원소는 s m과 cn의 내적으로 주어져요.
H tilde와 S의 원소는 모두 Hadamard 테스트를 사용해서 계산해요.
그러면 일반화된 고유값 문제는 이렇게 돼요.
위에서 언급했듯이, unitary Krylov 부분 공간의 차원 R은 초기
행렬 차원 N보다 지수적으로 작아요. 그래서 이 값 문제는 고전적으로 쉽게 풀 수 있어요.
정리하면, 기준 상태에서 시작해서 서로 다른 시간 동안 진화시켜 unitary
Krylov 부분 공간을 생성해요. Hamiltonian을 그 부분 공간에 투영하고 부분 공간
벡터들의 겹침도 추정해요. 마지막으로, 더 낮은 차원의 일반화된 값 문제를 고전적으로 풀어요. Krylov 기법을
고전적으로와 양자역학적으로 사용할 때 계산 비용을 결정하는 요소를 비교해봐요. 이미
고전 버전에 대해 간략히 설명했고, 모든 단계에서 고전적, 양자적 접근 간에 완벽한 유사점이 있는 건 아니에요. 하지만 이 표에 고려할
여러 단계의 스케일링이 정리되어 있어요. Hamiltonian은 일반적으로 동시에 측정할 수 없는 항들을 가지고 있다는 걸 기억해요. 왜냐하면
교환하지 않기 때문이에요. Hamiltonian의 항들을 동시에 측정할 수 있는 교환 Pauli 연산자 그룹으로 분류하고, 교환하지 않는 모든 항을 처리하려면 많은
그룹이 필요할 수 있어요. 양자 컴퓨터에서 H tilde를 구축하려면
Hamiltonian에서 교환 Pauli 문자열의 각 그룹에 대해 별도의 측정이 필요해요. 그리고 각각 많은 shots가 필요해요. 이걸 R
제곱개의 서로 다른 행렬 원소에 대해 해야 하는데, 서로 다른 시간 진화 인수의 R 제곱 조합에 해당해요.
이를 줄이는 방법도 있어요. 하지만 이 대략적인 계산에서 필요한 시간은 대략
shots 수 곱하기 교환 Pauli 항 그룹의 수 곱하기 r 제곱에 비례해요.
S의 원소를 추정해야 하는데, 이건 shots 수에 비례해서 증가해요.
r 세제곱에 비례해요. Hamiltonian의 교환 Pauli 그룹의 수가 비교적 적은 경우에 quantum Krylov 대각화가 유용할 수 있어요.
Hamiltonian에서요.
이 스케일링 의존성은 Krylov 방법이 유용한 응용 분야와 그렇지 않을 응용 분야를 시사해요.
일부 Hamiltonian은 qubit에 매핑될 때 많은 비가환 Pauli 문자열을 포함하는 높은 복잡도를 가져요.
소수의 교환 그룹으로 쉽게 분류할 수 없는 경우죠.
이건 양자 화학 문제에서 자주 나타나요. 예를 들어, 이 복잡도는 근접
양자 컴퓨터에 두 가지 주요 과제를 제기해요. 첫째, H tilde의 각 원소를 추정하는 것이 항의 수가
많아서 계산적으로 비싸져요. 둘째, 필요한 Trotter circuit이 지나치게 깊어져요. 이 두 가지 문제는
양자 컴퓨터가 오류 허용에 도달하면 덜 문제가 되겠지만, 근접 기간에는 고려해야 해요. 더 단순한 매핑을 가진 시스템도
양자 화학보다 Hamiltonian에 비가환 항이 너무 많으면 같은 장애물을 겪을 수 있어요.
Krylov 방법은 Hamiltonian을 비교적 적은 수의 교환 Pauli 그룹으로 분류할 수 있고
H를 Trotter circuit에 쉽게 구현할 수 있을 때 가장 유용해요. 이 두 조건이 모두 만족돼요. 예를 들어
물리학에서 관심 있는 많은 격자 모델에서요. 바닥 상태에 대해 거의 알려진 게 없을 때 KQD는 특히 유용해요.
이건 고유한 수렴 보장과 바닥 상태 지식이 부족해서
대안적인 방법들을 쓸 수 없는 시나리오에서의 적용 가능성 덕분이에요.
KQD는 강력한 도구지만, 특히 투영된 Hamiltonian의 각 원소와 Krylov 상태들의 겹침을 추정하는
시간 소모적인 측면은 개선의 여지가 있어요.
대안적인 접근법은 Trotter circuit을 사용해서 Krylov 상태를 근사하고, 그 다음
근사된 상태를 샘플링해서 계산 basis로의 투영을 얻고, 그런 다음 이 계산 basis 상태들이 생성하는 부분 공간으로
H를 투영하는 거예요.
적용 가능한 경우, sampling based Krylov quantum diagonalization, 즉 SKQD로 알려진 이 방법론은
전통적인 KQD에 비해 시간과 자원 요구량을 크게 줄일 가능성이 있어요.
SKQD에서 Krylov 부분 공간 기법과 샘플링 방법을 통합하는 것은
양자 알고리즘의 흥미로운 새로운 영역이에요.